digamos que tengo tres enteros muy bien
y tengo tres enteros que les voy a poner
nombres se llaman a b y c además estos
enteros son números positivos eso quiere
decir que son números naturales
esencialmente ok y estos tres enteros
estos tres números dijimos que son
enteros muy bien además tenemos otra
información tenemos que a más b si lo
dividimos en 13 también es un número
entero también es entero muy bien y eso
no siempre pasa verdad entonces esta
expresión es un entero pero no sólo eso
también tenemos otra propiedad que a es
un múltiplo es múltiplo de c
o bien esto es lo mismo que decir que es
divisible es divisible
en 13
es divisible en 13 esto es exactamente
lo mismo que a es múltiplo de seo que es
divisible en 13 es decir que si yo lo
divido en 13 eso nos da exactamente un
número entero entonces la pregunta para
todos es la siguiente será cierto que b
tiene que ser un entero tiene que ser
perdón si es un entero pero tiene que
ser un múltiplo de c
será cierto que ve tiene que ser
múltiplo de c y aquí nuevamente te
recomiendo que hagas una pausa en el
vídeo para que pienses tu propia
respuesta cómo explicarías tu sive puede
ser un múltiplo de ese o tiene que ser
un múltiplo de c o puede que sí puede
que no
aunque ya entonces ya que le diste una
pausa y que estamos de vuelta vamos a
pensar muy bien en este problema vamos a
reescribir esta expresión además ve en
13 es un entero entonces vamos a
reescribir lo porque además b sobre c
podemos utilizar la distributiva y that
y expresar lo como a en 13 más bien 13
muy bien entonces sabemos que esta suma
es un entero esto de aquí es un entero
esto de aquí todo completo eso no entero
pero no sólo eso sabemos que a es un
múltiplo de c y eso significa o bien que
si ya es divisible en 13 quiere decir
que yo al dividir a en 13 esto me queda
un número entero también es un entero
esté sumando entonces date cuenta de lo
siguiente tengo un entero que le estoy
sumando algo y nos da un entero así que
si eso pasa pues ese algo tiene que ser
un entero así que esto de aquí ve en 13
también tiene que ser un entero también
también tiene que ser entero
también es entero muy bien entonces
fíjate que si lo dividimos en 13 nos
resultó ser un entero pues eso es
justamente la definición de ser un
múltiplo de ser verdad que al dividirlo
en 13 nos dé un entero así que para que
eso para que eso sea cierto lo que debe
pasar es que de eso el múltiplo de c
entonces partimos de tres enteros
positivos muy bien si sumamos los dos
primeros y los dividimos en 3er
resultaba ser entero y también sabíamos
que a es un múltiplo de c entonces
utilizando esas propiedades separamos
esta expresión en una suma y si el
primero es entero y nos daba entero pues
el otro tenía que ser entero así que en
este caso b es un múltiplo de c así que
si nos preguntan b tiene que ser un
múltiplo de c
nosotros podemos responder sí sí lo es